I
for me it was a very I remember being
very young it's kind of funny yes I
remember exactly where I was when I said
yes you'll be doing science I use that
word science because she loved that
stuff so much and I stopped there I said
okay I know I'll be I made a commitment
she must have been like fourth or fifth
grade and that was like a done deal
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using us when it
comes to artificial intelligence dr.
Eric Horvitz is as passionate as he has
accomplished his contributions to the
field and service on the boards of
nearly every technical Academy and
Association in the country have earned
him the respect and awe of his
colleagues along with the position of
technical fellow and managing director
of Microsoft Research today dr. Hurwitz
talks about the goal of artificial
intelligence his vision for our
collaborative future with machines what
we can learn from the Wright brothers
and how a short stint of six months
maximum became an illustrious and in his
words joyful 25-year career at Microsoft
Research that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
you want to start off with a huge
question
let's go huge let's go huge and then
we'll go micro yeah what would you say
the ultimate goal of your work is what's
the goal of AI let me start with my work
my goals it's understand what the heck
is going on with minds how on earth do
what we understand to be tangles of
neurons cells sparking and popping and
communicating with each other how on
earth does that lead to this fluid
experience and I think I have a pretty
good handle on physics space and time
and force but questions about mind or a
real knockout
I decided as an undergraduate that as I
faced my next step in life whether it be
education or some sort of a research
position as a scientist that it would be
mastering some insights or knowledge
with effort no doubt about how brains
generated Minds so talk about that in
context of artificial intelligence and
what you're actually doing here I moved
from a focus on actual brains and the
PhD off to understand how brains worked
early on in graduate school into
computer science it was pretty clear to
me that the most promising way to
understand intelligence and principles
of intelligence no doubt at the
foundations of my own conscious
experience would be through computation
and that brought me to computer science
and computing and decision science and
principles of decision making principles
of how systems agents could observe
learn perceive fuse information to make
assessments and take action in the world
and even communicate with one another
through natural language did you start a
neuroscience then yes I did biophysics
at undergraduate and that I thought was
good preparation across the sciences for
understanding
what we knew about the Natural Sciences
which in the context of all the
knowledge there not that it's complete
set up a widening and gain gaping hole
when it came to how nervous systems work
we're still you know drowning in
mysteries about that that's why it's so
exciting and that's why when I do work
in AI artificial intelligence machine
intelligence their various phrases for
for this endeavor even small pups little
insights go a long way yeah you said
decision science is that actually field
yeah it is that we often say the
decision sciences there's a behavioral
component there are people that study
how people make decisions it's the
psychology of judgment and decision
making people study this because they
don't want to understand how it is that
humans react to advertisements how do
they make suboptimal decisions in
different settings how can they be
fooled
what's a hallucination or an illusion of
judgment analogous to the illusions we
have in our visual systems but then
another part of decision science is
looking at what's called formal or
normative models what's the ideal action
one should take under uncertainty when
you don't know exactly what will happen
and you don't know exactly what the
influence of your action will be and
maybe you don't even have enough time to
think about all possible actions but
have to make a decision because if you
wait you might be in trouble there's an
interesting idea called
and that we can actually compute called
the value of information in a decision
context we can actually think through is
it worth pausing and collecting more
data before I take an action in real
time and you know as you say it I'm
thinking of situations where you want to
make a fast decision and it might cost
you to wait but it might cost you way
more if you don't wait and gather that
information that you need you've just
written the abstract in my dissertation
at Stanford
I mean that's exactly what I worked on
you know I think so much of intelligence
is how well we do with limited resources
so I study this area and I'm still
fascinated by it thinking and acting
under bounded resources for thinking
bounded time bounded computation varying
time sometimes you don't know how much
time you have in your you have to have a
system we say has an any time response
or a flexible computing strategy so it's
like it'll think and think and think and
think and the patient might do something
you say I gotta act now right and in
fact in my dissertation we had this
model of a patient gasping for breath
and the problem was either A or B and
you had very different strategies with
different costs and benefits and you
were uncertain and the reasoner is
thinking away and huffing and puffing
and the probability of what it is is
changing over time and here's the cool
part the system had to know what was the
value of thinking longer to come up with
a better answer when you knew the
patient was crashing right I mean that's
high stakes you're working toward a
future of human AI collaboration where
AI will you've said these words
compliment assist leverage and extend
human capabilities talk about more
specifically what that future might look
like yeah it's interesting there's a
science to this and a very interesting
research direction or set of directions
and as a future I think you can
understand it best if I just start with
a little bit of the science so what I
imagine and the kind of work that we've
been doing on my team and some of our
colleagues have been doing with their
teams is imagining this notion of how do
we build computing systems given our
current technology that can do
perception and reasoning and
decision-making that are designed to
complement human minds human thinking
and that brings us down this very
interesting path of looking at all the
incredible literature and studies
studies to be done that characterize how
limited human beings are there's about a
hundred and twenty-five years or so of
rich studies of cognition have revealed
biases and blind spots and limitations
in all human beings it's part of our
natural human substrate of of our minds
could we build systems that understand
in detail and in context the things that
you'll forget your ability to do two
things at once
and how to help you balance multitasking
for example understanding how you
visualize what your learning challenges
might be in any setting what you
consider hard why is that math concept
hard to get and you can imagine systems
that understand us so deeply someday
that they beautifully compliment us they
know when to come forward they're almost
invisible but they extend us now part of
the trick there is not just
complementarity its coordination when
how does a mix of initiatives work where
a machine will do one thing and then a
human takes over I love some of the work
going on my colleagues at Johns Hopkins
you can imagine a computer science
department at Johns Hopkins we were
looking at like surgical robots but
what's interesting in this work and it
really captures what that we do as well
in the more in the intellectual space is
you see a human surgeon that's working
so let's say do a certain kind of stitch
and it's a give and take where the robot
system is watching in the same way that
they're watching they're coordinating
with each other and it's a back and
forth a give-and-take we're working
together faster progress can be made
this Thomas greatest summer is greater
than one so you see the ability to
augment a human being with a system that
is not as good but it's complementing
humans in a particular way by
recognizing blind spots one of your
favorite books is David McCullough's
biography of the Wright brothers yeah I
loved it you commented how amazing it
was that in 50 summers the aviation
industry went from canvas flopping on a
beach
the Boeing 707 what I loved about that
book is that a team in this case very
close brothers actually turned us the
whole family right had this vision and
they dedicated every ounce of their
creative effort to thinking it through I
read that book I savored it and I bought
a copy for my larger team and I said
please please read every word of this
book I did that for several reasons
including the passion the focus the end
to end the analogy of aerodynamics and
principles understanding them with the
way we're trying to understand AI we can
go from people and what we understand
and our current artifacts they were
building but really take it forward into
a working system that captures the
essence of intelligence in my mind was
the kind of pursuit that the Wright
brothers were doing and also and this is
the second reason why I like that book
and the analogy of our mission today in
AI to the long-term aspirations for
humans to fly even in the late 19th
century in the early 20th century
everything air flight was considered a
flaky challenging endeavor that probably
wouldn't have pay off it seemed almost
unreachable in a deep way and in that
context we had folks who just knew
better in their hearts that this was
doable
and it could be done with with through
intellect and perseverance and I just
was talking today to a group visitors
that asked but will we were with AI and
I said look it's been a slog it's been
slow no matter what you hear about AI we
haven't gotten systems up to the level
of a toddler when it comes to
understanding common sense social
relationships the physics of gravity
containment of liquids like this water
here in this glass in front of you it's
beyond our systems today and we still
don't know so much about the mysteries
of how for example toddlers learn so
quickly we don't understand
how people are situated and make it
through life and understand one another
so well models of mind how do people go
from one thing to the other with all
their skills how are all these
competencies coordinated and what is
this thing called consciousness so that
we use the word consciousness to refer
to what does that come from
what are these subjective states or
these qualia we have no idea we have
theories and reflections but they're not
really based in any scientific theories
just yet
however is it possible in 50 summers we
have a whole new world we have big
surprises afoot we understand how Minds
work so let me switch over for a second
we're still on the book in one of the
most interesting parts of the book to me
an observer of the early efforts of the
Wright brothers said we believe in a
good God a bad devil and a hot hell and
more than anything else we believe that
God did not intend that man should fly
so what do you say to the modern day
technology naysayers particularly the
brilliant innovative successful
technologists who not only cautioned
that we're heading into dangerous
territory with AI but say things like
literally we're summoning the demon you
know I think in many ways I resonate
with comments like that cuz I know where
they're coming from if we believe we can
master principles upon which our own
minds operate to build systems that have
abilities like humans and we then can
say things like oh but can we multiply
that in a great way and have more
powerful versions of these systems that
could outwit humans you can imagine that
line of reasoning raising important
questions about the safety of designing
systems one day it turns out that many
things that we want to do in the short
term to ensure the safety of AI systems
being used in high stakes areas and
keeping them robust and trustworthy are
aligns with where you'd go and how you'd
make the larger
more super intelligent system safe as
well so we're on the right track I think
and I think people are thinking about
these issues which is a very very good
thing I think it's also important since
we don't really know the future to
reflect a bit about maybe more than a
bit but to gather together experts and
to envision good outcomes and
not-so-good outcomes so recently last
February I organized a meeting with a
couple of colleagues where we entitled
the meeting envisioning and disrupting
adverse AI outcomes the initial title of
that meeting if you don't talk about was
envisioning and disrupting our worst
case AI nightmares and what we did was
we asked about 50 computer scientists
and other people in affiliated fields to
write down exactly what their fears were
or these worst-case nightmares ain't
clearly just you know and not just write
them down but we had a kind of a form
you filled out is it like a lock-in
permanent thing is a temporary causes a
big disaster doesn't involve lives
does it involve politics and we had a
little forum and then we also said now
make sure you fill out exactly the steps
the trajectory that we went on that got
us to that bad state and make sure it's
bulletproof because we're gonna have a
blue team and a red team and the red
team is gonna defend your case the blue
team is gonna tear it apart and they're
gonna do it live in real time and we had
six scenarios what could possibly go
wrong yes that's it was all about but my
point is that people talk about worrying
and anxiety it feels better to get
active in if you do have a way or
anxiety let's get it crisp and let's put
our minds to it and I tend to have an
optimistic side mostly that doesn't
blind me to hearing about negative
implications and costs and downsides for
AI in the short term or a long term I
think we should study this if there are
some failure points and costly outcomes
we want to think through
how to solve them in a proactive manner
now if we can't let's have a good time
now and enjoy all you can but but I'm
optimistic that we can well yeah and I
mean your your philosophy that I'm
hearing is let's approach it with a
positive outlook and instead of being
Luddites that sort of stick wrenches in
the machines or the Amish that say you
know the button goes far enough the
zipper goes too far no one will stop the
march of our curiosity the science we're
going to learn more about Minds we're
going to learn more about hoot as we are
we're going to learn more about how to
build intelligences that's just going to
happen the question is can we invest
enough and how much we invest as we go
doing it in a careful way and as we go
address not just rough edges that we can
see but really think broadly as to what
could go wrong anyway so let's go from
the specific to the general because you
have said that you believe in
technology's ability to make human life
more meaningful what do you mean by that
well there's been a lot of discussion
afoot about the rise of competencies of
machines doing intellectual work and
robotic work one of my visions for the
future I don't know if we're going to
get there but my optimistic side
believes we will and wants us to is that
with the rise of an ubiquity of machine
intellect in our lives both in
human-like intelligences automatic
robots they're helping us as coaches and
as supportive assistants of various
kinds and intelligences in the
background and lots of automation
everywhere that against that background
the value of what's uniquely human will
rise to become even more valued than it
is today
you know I was recently listening to a
song that was written by a machine
actually we ascribe it to attributed to
Xiao Weis we have people in our China
lab that showed how you can have an AI
system
use deep learning to learn how to write
not just the beautiful song but poetic
lyrics to go with it
when I hear songs I think I will always
want it to be songs written by a human
being who's experienced what they're
singing about when I hear a
country-western song you know I just was
listening to I don't I put that Tesla on
country-western Channel and I won but
tear my eye and I was thinking you know
what a machine ever put a tear in my eye
I'm not so sure I want a human being at
the other end humans want to connect
with human beings as teachers as doctors
as caregivers as songwriters as artists
that will never go away and I see it
being amplified in a world of automation
I love that that in itself makes me so
happy that you're actually running this
joint
I guess my position gives me this my
role here I guess it gives me a sense
for what's coming maybe earlier than
some people see it or the trend so I get
to sit and listen to people celebrating
shall I sing in this beautiful song and
it is beautiful I didn't recognize the
lyrics of DOE in Chinese but it really
got me thinking that I want you know
Waylon Jennings to have been through
this experience and to sing to me about
it yeah at the machine
to use classic marketing language what's
the value proposition of doing research
as opposed to another place where
somebody who was you 25 years ago right
now would look into what do I want to do
I'm a best and brightest to use a cliche
where am I gonna go and what am I going
to do why would they go into research
well you know for me I've always been
the kind of person that never got to the
end of my wise
you know why this why that but but why
but that doesn't ask my question why
would that be the case and I've noticed
that I got a lot of pleasure out of that
my mind is driven to ask questions and
when I come to an answer that I didn't
expect I get such a burst of pleasure so
that's just the way I live I'm in the
exact right spot for having a joyful
experience creating I think one of the
deepest values at Microsoft Research and
in other labs is creativity creation
coming up with new ideas that have never
been thought of before combining two
sort of well-known ideas into a whole
new innovative combination that leads to
a whole new concept if doing that also
brings up answers to why is it's
fabulous to learn more as you go being
in a research lab puts you in a world
where you're on a lifelong learning
crashing wave of lifelong learning
you're always kind of surfing this wave
of the unknown and you look to your left
and right it's kind of funny I'm
visualizing this right now I'm seeing
people that I know and you see your
buddy surfing to once in a while wiping
out and getting up again and it's like a
big surfing party on the edge of what's
unknown and it's very very joyful
exciting and interesting you know when I
came to Microsoft research I said I come
up here for six months maximum I didn't
really know what Microsoft was doing and
they acquired our little startup we had
during my Stanford graduate school days
we were actually fine to take our PhD
dissertation work
such great stuff this Bayesian reasoning
and get it out into the world on these
new things called pcs which seem to be
just as powerful as some of the Lisp
machines we were using at Stanford but I
came up here and I thought six months
and I'm back to going my path to a
university which is also research and
that my comment is that Here I am almost
25 years later and I feel like I'm just
starting like just starting it's like I
feel like okay I just got here and we
have so much more to do and it's way
more than six months so what would a
computer science student or somebody in
university whether they're in undergrad
or graduate school what would they be
thinking as as they are planning their
career yeah my sense has been this what
I tried to do as an undergraduate to try
to spend some time with yourself to
understand broadly what brings you
delights and happiness and what what's
kind of exciting to you I think we all
have different sets of aesthetics and
different notions about topics and
possibilities and our conceptions of
jobs that turn us on the make us give us
excitement and for me it was a very I
remember being very young it's kind of
funny I remember exactly where I was
when I said yes you'll be doing science
leave that word science because you love
that stuff so much and I stopped there I
said okay I know I'll be I made a
commitment I think you must have been
like fourth or fifth grade and that was
like a done deal
but then what do you do I liked
everything I was excited about biology
chemistry math physics
it's incredible books from the the
Merrick Library in New York house always
full of books
god knows what I'll be doing today if it
would be the Internet I'd be having a
blast but my comment is that I felt like
it's best as an undergraduate to take
out time to explore around the midpoint
of what you think you would probably
like the
commit to being too narrow too soon you
heard my story I came to Stanford MD PhD
neurobiology I thought I really want an
MD well it's broadening and explore
human minds not just rats someday and
maybe it'll be a breakthrough I can
actually understand brains human brains
but I remember as I moved into AI
starting out neurobiology I always had
the sense of I can't get there all at
once kinda just take another step closer
another step closer a lab I find
interesting a mentor a research for I
found interesting go talk to them
closer closer then I remember funny
saying it was like 1984 and a half I
remember saying I'm doing what I want to
be doing now and I'm gonna go hard on it
now and it was a I to learn more about
dr. Eric Horvitz and the Microsoft
Research vision for the future of
artificial intelligence visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]